next situation is the boys and girls
completely separate right so all the
boys together write a five of them all
together and then all of the girls or
together
okay does that make sense so here's one
is it I can do boy boy boy and then all
the girls over this son right so this is
the arrangement that I'm after
okay now you tell me how would you begin
doing this remember there's lots of
different ways that are all valid how
might you approach the number of ways
any suggestions think about how I I
structured the previous question as well
the first thing I want to do is lock
something anything in position right now
in this case here part C right my my
standard unit was a couple okay much of
the frustration singles in the crowd
like me in your twelve but now I don't
have come right now i've got groups of
groups of five wait
and I've got two spots for them does
that make sense okay
so here's what I do I lock in one group
of five and I just put them somewhere
one two three four five their problems
okay how many ways are there for me to
check in the other group answer one way
they're only five seats left right one
okay so I placed say the boys as a group
of five then I place the girls as you
could be five but then just like in the
couple's situation within those groups
they can rearrange themselves right so
for instance how many ways can the boys
rearrange themselves five factorial and
then the girls can also rearrange
themselves into five factorial ways okay
so they've got one hundred and fourteen
thousand for something like that
okay last situation I'll so sad a
breakup right so let's go back to the
Part C we had five couples right by
couples but suppose one of the couple's
breaks up so we don't want to we don't
want to play this one that's a bad idea
okay the four couples are still together
they're okay they're like this right but
the other two you want to keep them far
apart okay I'm going to pause we just
built up all these approaches for doing
it okay I want you to have them just
breathing off the table I know sorry
buddy I want you to think about how you
would do it and how you would where you
would start right and then how you would
explain how your weight gets the right
number of ways and by the way I don't
know who said it but this is really good
quote that says a problem well phrased
is half solved problem well phrase this
half salt because if you phrase it the
right way it makes it very obvious what
way you should proceed
and then the rest of it's just cruel
right so here's the way I'm going to
phrase it it's a breakup right so you've
got four couples and then you've got the
other two two individuals right so these
here these are the things I need to
place okay and then I'll work about work
out their internal rearrangements
afterwards okay just like I've been
doing all the way through okay so you
know in the case of the couple's how
many couples did I have to place I have
five couples in the case of having all
of the boys together and all the girls
together how many units objects did I
need to place I need to place two right
so I placed one and then because it's a
circle there's only one other place for
them things to be okay now you have a
look at this how many objects do I need
to place and the answer is six okay so I
have six objects so I'm going to put
I'll do it like this because this you
might find this a little more helpful
one two three
five six okay there you go it's a life
up or six different spots for things to
be put into okay now the reason why this
is a powerful approach is because a lot
of people have gotten sort of hamstrung
over saying well you know there's one
seat here which means they're going to
be gap of one seat or they might not be
capable
there could be gap duties so three or it
gets a little more confusing can you see
in this arrangement I don't care about
where the individual seats are okay all
i care is about where these guys are in
relation to each other okay so I begin
the way I usually do by fixing someone
in place okay so let's put the boy here
right once I place the boy okay
the girl is now limited in where she can
go right now you can think in terms of
oh I have to put a couple here in here I
prefer and I think it's probably like
mathematically easier to say or where
can the gossip and the answer is here
here or here there are three places that
I can put the girl okay now once I place
them I don't care where anyone else goes
I just rearrange all the couples
wherever how many couples must I arrange
for and there are four factorial ways to
arrange them yes okay I'm almost done
I've put all of the units in their place
now okay but then you know how formulas
like they alternate who gets beef and
chicken or whatever and like you know
one of these guys is like I don't want
beef so you know they swap places so we
can do all of this shuffling right but I
don't have five couples do I I've only
got four
okay which gives you I think the number
you're not with is 1152 which is a bit
of a relief because even though it's
socially awkward at least there's a look
there's like really - two ways for us to
minimize that awkwardness yes you mean
here okay good question
why is this not three factorial okay now
it all depends on and I haven't I
haven't written it admittedly but
hopefully I talked through it slowly
enough you've got to know what each of
these means gotta know what each number
means right so what was the one about it
was fixing a person the boy in my case
okay then what was this fall and the
answer was I was not arranging a bunch
of things I was arranging one thing the
girl right and she can be in one of
three places there are three ways to
place the girl right so that's why it's
three does that make sense so if you
wanna think about it this way right here
are three spots right and the girl can
be in this spot or she can be in this
spot or she can be in this spot and
because I'm not placing three objects
into those three spots that's why I
don't have three factorial I'm only
placing one object into those three
spots make sense
okay so big tips draw a diagram for
yourself learn what each thing is there
for right and that way you can trace
that if an error has crept in yeah
what does this represent what's this
about okay so this part is about after
having placed the couple's and then
place the individuals now I can see the
couple's themselves internally they can
swap so there are only four couples
though rather than five as they were in
this case but I can't switch the boy and
the girl because I fixed him right if I
can switch the boy and the girl I will
come up with okay so then I will apply
to but then I've got exactly twice as
many arrangements as I've ever counted
right so that's why I don't don't over
count him just leave it one okay he's
been done with